قبله شاكيرا الحانيه عوده شيرين انجاز
تاريخي لتايلور سويفت وحفلات جماهيريه في
الرياض والقاهره اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصفها بليله حالمه فوق الخيال هكذا كانت
اجواء حفل الفنان الاماراتي حسين الجسمي
في موسم الرياضه الذي شاركته فيها المغنيه
العراقيه اصيل هميم والمغني السعودي
يا نهار مننا
والفرات نار
وسبقها لقاء تجدد بين الجمهور السعودي
والهضبه الذي قال عنه رئيس هيئه الترفيه
في المملكه تركي ال الشيخ بتغريده له على
تويتر كالعاده عمرو دياب يثبت انه رقم صعب
في موسم الرياض في اشاره الى جماهيريه
الحفل الذي احياه الفنان المصري مؤخرا ضمن
فعاليات الموسم
[ضحك]
الكبير على مواقع التواصل بالعالم العربي
حفل الاصاله الذي اختتمت فيه فعاليات
الدوله الحاديه والثلاثين من مهرجان
الموسيقى العربيه بدار الاوبرا المصريه
بالقاهره
وي
[موسيقى]
روحوا كما حقق خبر مغادره الفنان المصري
شيرين عبد الوهاب المستشفى تفاعلا كبيرا
على مواقع التواصل في العالم العربي وذلك
فورا اعلان محاميه ياسر قدوش الخبر عبد
حسابه الرسمي على فيسبوك وتلاه بيان اصدره
الفنان مصطفى كامل نقيب المهني الموسيقيه
في مصر قال فيه انه تحدث الى شيرين وطمع
الجمهورها المصري والعربي بانها اصبحت في
منزلها وبكامل صحتها ولياقتها وابتسامتها
الجميله بحسب تعبيره ولم يخرج سيناري
وخروج شيرين من المستشفى بعد ثلاث اسابيع
من الدراما حيث سبقه بساعات تسجيل لها
انشره محاميه ياسر القنطوش تناشده في
اخراجها من المستشفى ولم يتسنى التاكد
بشكل مستقل مما ورد في التسجيل
امي ما تفعل معه رواد مواقع التواصل حول
العالم الاسبوع الماضي مقطع فيديو لشاكيرا
وهي تقبل قدمي والدها بعد ان بدات صحته
بالتحسن المغني الكولومبيه من اصل لبناني
علقت على الفيديو الذي نشرته عبر حسابها
الرسمي على انستغرام الحياه هي ما يحدث
بين زيارات المستشفى وازياء الهالوين
عالميا ايضا حققت المغنيه الامريكيه
تايلور سويفت تفاعلا واسعا على مواقع
التواصل بالاعلان عن كونها اول مغنيه في
التاريخ تتصدر جميعا فئات قائمه افضل عشر
اغنيات فرديه في الولايات المتحده بحسب
تصنيف بيلبرت بفضل احدث البوماتها ميد
نايت واعرضت عن سعادتها بهذا الانجاز في
تغريده نشرتها عبر حسابها رسمي على تويتر
قائله 10 من اصل 10 من بين 100 اصدار في
الالبوم العاشر انا في قمه النشوه
واخيرا اختتمت الدوله الثالثه والثلاثين
من ايام قرطاج السينمائيه فعالياتها في
تونس السبت الماضي وفاز الفيلم التنزاني
الثوار بالثانيه الذهبي كبرى جوائز
المهرجان وحصل فيلم تحت الشجره للمخرجه
التونسيهري على الثاني في الفضي اما
الثاني في البرونزي فكان من نصيب فيلم شرف
للمخرج المصري سمير نصر